house gum rose my name is Pierre pack
I'm back from a little break you
probably haven't even noticed but still
today we're gonna play poker draw and
it's the probably the best website on
the internet the rules are you have 45
seconds to draw a random Pokemon I
thought I'd play this with you bros so
I'm not gonna tell you which one I'm
drawing you just have to guess I'm gonna
draw a couple we'll see how many right
once you get you ready let's do dias
this one it's probably my favorite
because it's probably the most sexual
pokemon on the market he does not care
about taking you out on a date first
he is just all about dad you probably
guessed it already didn't ya you don't
know what pokemon is you prefer Digimon
Digimon digital monsters Digimon do a
sharp yard all right uh wait I forgot a
detail there we go
[ __ ] okay that was licky tongue we'll
see how many right you get in the end
next one oh this this one is good
there's no way I can draw well at 45
seconds so excuse me princess don't
blame me if you can't guess alright my
drawing skills are impeccable you should
know this one let's come on and woman
I'm drawing little toads on him that's
ghost Peppa now that's a pretty good hip
now I would say that's probably like 105
percent accurate or something yeah this
is my new wallpaper
what a great wallpaper your Pokemon are
you confused cuz you should be a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] don't waste time drawing that
blasphemy oh god oh god ah this is hard
that's what she said ah sexual innuendo
there leaking there crying did you get
it Machamp that's a pretty good Machamp
I would say I like his boobs next one oh
this good what the [ __ ] is going on here
well I'm done
what what am I getting something wrong
with you not me
oh you can see my drawings up there what
is that that is probably the best
Pikachu I've ever seen in my life
did you get it poliwag if you can't get
this one then I'm sorry we're not you're
not a bro anymore this is probably the
greatest pokemon of all time Nintendo
should just hire me and and make me
droll the Pokemon Magikarp all right I'm
gonna invite you buzz come draw with me
I just don't want to crash the website
god damn it we crashed the website Wow I
let the tweet out for literally five
seconds are you [ __ ] kidding me
thanks well this was fun
oh cool you can see what other people
draw that's for sanic sanic what are you
doing here static goddamnit sanic
alright new one uh this one is a total
Sugoi kawaii it's also famous for having
that swag yes swaggy think that's how
you spell it
No draw a little mustache Oh final
details upside-down penis okay finished
did you guess it
Dragonite while you bros totally what
what did you do to the website you had
one job
god damn you bros ah ok it's back I
think this game is probably like the
most hardcore game of all time like the
pressure of drawing Pokemon really fast
now everyone can handle that [ __ ] not
everyone can pull up the pressure I'm
just saying how can you not guess this
this is obviously pitbull I never
realized how [ __ ] kawaii pitbull is
there we go so Sugoi
forgot our little detail there there we
go yeah all good Beedrill I'm gonna have
you guessed so far that's great I can't
hear you but still I appreciate it and
won't give me a Pokemon come on
it's really demands a lot of talent and
I have just probably too much talent as
you can see this is what happens when
you have too much talent for us [ __ ]
just gets weird man it just gets really
weird what are you doing
whose dad Pokemon it's our buck goddamn
you crashed your website stop alright
well I guess that's that's enough for
now
leave a like if you wanted me to play
more of this and if you got all of them
right if you didn't go ahead and like
anyway
cuz I'm a [ __ ] hey at least I'm honest
thank you for watching this video bros
as always here's the brofist for you
stay awesome bros I know you will
aha